हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल। तो सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे
रही है? पहले जल्दी से यह बताइए।
सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है? आई एम
ऑडिबल लाउड एंड क्लियर गाइस
बिल्कुल सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है
ओके थैंक यू एवरीवन
तो थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं एक से दो मिनट
के लिए स्टूडेंट्स को ज्वाइन होने देते
हैं और
उसके उसके बाद कंटिन्यू करेंगे सेशन को।
तब तक के लिए मुझे बताइए कि प्रीवियस
क्लास में किसी का कोई डाउट था? किसी का
कोई भी डाउट हो
हम
प्रीवियस क्लास से रिलेटेड किसी का कोई भी
डाउट है जिसको कुछ पूछना है तो
अच्छी बात है अगर आप फर्स्ट टाइम आए हो तो
क्योंकि जो फर्स्ट टाइम आता है तो चाहे
कभी भी आता है मेरी क्लास में उसके लिए
कभी भी लास्ट टाइम नहीं होता। वो हमेशा
दोबारा आने की कोशिश करता है हमारी
क्लासेस में बिकॉज़ हमारी क्लासेस होती ही
इतनी इंटरेस्टिंग है कि आप लोगों को हमारी
सीरीज में मजा आता है।
सिर्फ फाइल भेजने के लिए मुझे कोई रास्ता
ही नहीं मिल रहा क्योंकि Google ड्राइव का
लिंक मैं शेयर नहीं कर सकता बिकॉज़ ऑफ माय
प्राइवेसी और बाकी मेरे पास कोई रास्ता
मिल नहीं रहा है कि मैं कैसे उसको शेयर
करूं क्योंकि WhatsApp जो चैनल है उसमें
डायरेक्टली हम उसको शेयर नहीं कर सकते
क्योंकि WhatsApp में ऐसा कोई ऑप्शन आता
ही नहीं तो
समझ नहीं आ रहा कि कैसे आप लोगों को वो
शेयर करूं वो फाइल बट
निकालता हूं कोई अल्टरनेट वे आप लोगों के
लिए
यार इंग्लिश या हिंदी में टाइप कर लीजिए
सबसे बढ़िया रहेगा।
चलो सेशन को स्टार्ट करें फिर
सेशन को स्टार्ट करें फिर
मुझे पता है स्टूडेंट्स नहीं आएंगे और मैं
आपको पहले ही बता देता हूं यह सेशन सच में
आपके एडवांस लेवल का सेशन है क्योंकि कोई
बिगिनियर लेवल का सेशन नहीं है क्योंकि जो
यह सेशन है ना आपके वेब के जितने भी हैं
उसमें आपको नेटवर्किंग की नॉलेज बहुत
मायने रखती है क्योंकि अगर आपको
नेटवर्किंग की नॉलेज नहीं है तो आपके साथ
क्या है प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट हो सकती हैं कि
आपको बहुत सारी चीजें आपको समझ में नहीं
आएंगी वायरस शार्क में हम इतनी सारी चीजें
करते हैं। ये तो काफी बेसिक लेवल्स पे
हैं। तो आप क्या कर रहे हो कि जब टी शार्क
यूज करते हो या बाकी सारी चीजें यूज करोगे
ना तो
क्या होगा कि वहां पर आपको बहुत सारी चीज
समझ में नहीं आती पैकेज और ये क्योंकि
आपको नेटवर्किंग की नॉलेज नहीं होती
क्योंकि वही पेन टेस्टिंग एक प्रकार से
नेटवर्क पेन टेस्टिंग के अंदर ही आती है
क्योंकि आपको सारा काम नेटवर्क से डील
करना पड़ता है। प्रोटोकॉल से डील करना
पड़ता है। ओके तो
मैं आपको यही चीज बोलूंगा कि आप लोगों को
नेटवर्किंग की नॉलेज भी होनी चाहिए और अगर
आप साइबर सिक्योरिटी में लॉन्ग टाइम टिके
रहना चाहते हो कि आप जस्ट टाइम पास के लिए
नहीं आए हो आपको सच में अपना करियर बनाना
है तो आपको नेटवर्किंग सीख सीखनी ही
पड़ेगी। आपको इतना लेवल तो आना पड़ेगा कि
आपको सारी चीजें समझ में आ जाए। क्योंकि
अगर आप एथिकल हैकिंग सीख रहे हो चलो चल
जाएगा स्टार्टिंग लेवल पर बट आप एडवांस
लेवल पर जाओगे या हम बात करते 100
एनालिस्ट टीम की बात करें तो उसमें पूरा
आपको नेटवर्किंग के साथ डील करना पड़ता है
और अगर नेटवर्किंग एंड पॉइंट एनालिसिस
आपको लोग पढ़ने आने चाहिए। ये सारी चीजें
आपको नॉलेज होनी चाहिए। बिकॉज़ आप साइबर
सिक्योरिटी फील्ड में जब आपने एंटर करना
स्टार्ट कर दिया तो यह सारी चीजें आपके
लिए काफी क्रूशियल हो जाती है। काफी
इंपॉर्टेंट हो जाती है।
ओके तो
मैं अच्छा हूं एवरीवन आई एम फाइन अनिकेत
ठाकुर एंड
आई होप कि आप लोग भी अच्छे ही होंगे तो हम
सेशन को भी स्टार्ट करते हैं क्योंकि काफी
काफी इंपॉर्टेंट सेशन है और ये सेशन मैं
छोटे-छोटे इसलिए ले रहा हूं क्योंकि ताकि
आप लोग बोर ना हो। आप लोगों को क्लासेस
में मजा आए या आप लोगों के लिए ऐसा ना लगे
कि आप लोगों को टेस्ट मतलब आप टाइम पास के
लिए आए हो या मैं आपका टाइम पास करवा रहा
हूं। ऐसा कुछ नहीं होने वाला। तो हम एक
काम करते हैं। आज का जो टॉपिक है काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक है। हम इस पर बात करने
वाले हैं। तो आज जो हम बात करने वाले हैं
ना जो हमारी है शिप ओवर टीएलएस प्लस में
आरटीपी ट्रैफिक एनालिसिस जो हमारा टॉपिक
रहने वाला है जो हमारा मेन फोकस है वो मेन
फोकस किस पे हमारा शिप ओवर टीएलएस प्लस
में आरटीपी ट्रैफिक और अभी तक की क्लासेस
में आप लोगों को इतनी नॉलेज तो हो चुकी है
कि
शिप क्या होता है और आरटीपी क्या होता है
और टीएलएस की नॉलेज आपको पहले से ही
एटलीस्ट होनी चाहिए। तो हां हम सबको पता
है कि शिप और आरटीपी केस में चार टाइप के
ट्रैफिक के साथ हम डील करने वाले हैं।
जिनमें से हमने जो फर्स्ट ट्रैफिक थी शिप
प्लस में आरटीपी उसके साथ डील कर लिया। अब
रही बात हमारी sh ओवर टीएलएस प्लस में
आरटीपी। अभी आप लोग बताइए कि आपको क्या लग
रहा है कि हम किस चीज के साथ डील करने
वाले हैं या जो हमारा आज का जो यूज़ यूज़
केस है सिर्फ ओवरtls प्लस में आरटीपी कि
वो क्या है या आप लोगों को क्या लगता है
कि आज हम किसके साथ पंगा लेने जा रहे हैं
या किस चीज के साथ हम डील करने के लिए जा
रहे हैं आप लोग क्या सोचते हो
ओके आप लोग क्या सोचते हो बताओ कि हम किस
चीज के साथ पंगा लेने के लिए जा रही है।
आप लोगों के दिमाग में क्या है? या मेरे
कहने का मतलब है कि sh ओवर टीएलएस प्लस
में आरटीपी से आपका क्या मतलब है? शिप ओवर
टीएलएस प्लस में आरटीपी से आपका क्या मतलब
है? प्लीज सेशन में अब्यूज मत कीजिए। ओके?
तो बताइए
आप लोगों को शिप प्लस आरटीपी जो शिप ओवर
टीएलएस प्लस में आरटीपी से आपको क्या समझ
में आ रहा है कि हम किस चीज के साथ डील
करने वाले होंगे? जल्दी से बताइए चैट में।
मैं आपका वेट कर रहा हूं क्योंकि जो हमारा
फोकस है यही है। तो एटलीस्ट एक चीज
क्लेरिटी होनी चाहिए आपके दिमाग में कि हम
किस बला से पंगा लेने के लिए जा रहे हैं
अभी? बताइए आप लोगों को क्या लगता है?
बताइए आप लोगों को क्या लगता है कि हम किस
चीज के साथ डील करने वाले हैं? अभी
कोई भी है स्टूडेंट जो चैट में आंसर करना
चाहेगा। कोई भी स्टूडेंट
या आंसर की बजाय क्लास को लेफ्ट करना पसंद
करोगे। बताओ
अनिकेत ठाकुर। आई एम आस्किंग शिप ओवर
टीएलएस प्लस में आरटीपी से आप क्या समझते
हो वो तो हमें पता है कि हम इसके ट्रैफिक
से डील करने वाले हैं बट बट आप इससे क्या
समझते हो
आप समझते क्या हो इस चीज से
देखो आज का हमारा सिनेरियो है शिप हमारा
इंक्रिप्टेड और आरटीपी आपका नॉट
इंक्रिप्टेड मतलब क्या है कि जो आपका सेशन
है या जो हैंडशक होता है वह आपका सिक्योर
रहेगा और जो आपका ऑडियो है वह क्या रहेगा
आपका अनइंकिप्टेड
यही सिनेरियो है हमारा यही सिनेरियो है कि
सेशन हमारा सिक्योर है और हमारी जो ऑडियो
ट्रैवल कर रही है वह अनसिक्योर है
अनइंकिप्टेड है वह इंक्रिप्टेड नहीं है आई
एम राइट एवरीवन।
क्या मैं सही बोल रहा हूं?
तो चलिए फिर अगर मैं आप लोग से सही बोल
रहा हूं। तो चलिए हमारे यूज़ केसेस के आपके
शिप और टीएलएस में सबसे पहले नॉर्मल कॉल
टू पार्टीज को एनालाइज करेंगे। ओपन विद
वसार। हम किसके साथ ओपन करते हैं? अभी
वसार के साथ। तो चलिए यह हमारा ट्रैफिक
है। यह आपको दिखाई दे रहा होगा। यह हमारा
वो हैंड पिकैप फाइल है जो दो लोगों के बीच
की बातचीत है। तो सबसे पहले हम एक फ़िल्टर
अप्लाई करके देखते हैं। तो एक काम करते
हैं। मैं इसमें व्यू करके देता हूं। ज़ूम
कर पाएंगे हम इसमें। ज़ूम इन। ओके। शायद
ज़ूम इन कर पा रहे हैं हम। सबको दिखाई दे
रहा होगा। परफेक्ट फाइन। तो अभी हम क्या
कर रहे हैं? हम सबसे पहले एक फ़्टर अप्लाई
कर रहे हैं। शिप। हमने एक फ़िल्टर अप्लाई
किया शिप और हिट एंटर किया। नथिंग वी विल
फाइंड। हमें कुछ भी इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं आई।
हमने क्या किया? शिप सर्च किया फ़्टर के
अंदर और हमें कोई भी ट्रैफिक नहीं मिला।
चलिए भैया आरटीपी ट्रैफिक रखते हैं हम और
हिट एंटर करते हैं। अभी सॉरी
इसको एक काम करता हूं मैं एक बार के लिए
मैं इसको हटा देता हूं क्योंकि मैं आपको
अभी के लिए यह आ गया बट यह नहीं आएगा।
ओके
अब दूसरी ट्रैफिक एनालाइज करते हैं। चलो
इसको मैं बंद करता हूं क्योंकि इसमें आ
गया कॉन्फ्रेंस को कॉल टू वॉइस मेल में
देखते हैं हम सबसे पहले। चलो
क्योंकि मैं आपको जो यूज़ केस सिनेरियो
दिखाना चाहता हूं वो यह है। हमने शिप
फाइंड आउट किया नहीं मिला। अगर हमने
आरटीपी को फाइंड आउट किया इसमें भी आ रहा
है। ओके मैं हटा ही देता हूं। इसमें एक
चीज को हटा ही देता हूं। वो क्या है?
डिकोड एज
क्या होता था?
ओके। अभी बताओ कि आपको क्या लगता है? मैं
इसको फिर से ओपन करता हूं।
आरटीपी
अभी कोई आरटीपी ट्रैफिक आ रहा है? कोई भी
आरटीपी ट्रैफिक आपको दिखाई दे रहा है?
ओके सबको ओके सबको सुनाई दे रहा है मे बी
सम नेटवर्क इशू वर देयर
कोई बफरिंग तो नहीं हो रही फाइन एवरी
एवरीवन
या मुझे आंसर कीजिए। तो जब हमें शिफ्ट
किया कोई ट्रैफिक नहीं मिला। आरटीपी किया
कोई ट्रैफिक नहीं मिला। अब मेरा सवाल आप
लोगों से क्या यह पिक फाइल में वफ डाटा
है?
पिकअप फाइल में वॉइस डाटा है। आप लोगों को
क्या लगता है? होगा। बट चलो एक काम करते
हैं। अभी हम कुछ फिल्टर अप्लाई नहीं करते।
नॉर्मल ट्रैफिक है। चलिए एक काम करते हैं
हम। गो टू टेलीफोनी शिफ्ट फ्लो। यहां पर
भी कोई डाटा नहीं है। यहां पर भी कोई डाटा
नहीं है। इट्स ओके। चलिए हम एक और दूसरा
तरीका जो अभी तक हमने सीखा था। गो टू
आरटीपी आरटीपी स्ट्रीम। नो आरटीपी
स्ट्रीम।
मतलब शिफ्ट फ्लो चेक किया ब्लैंक।
ओके। आरटीपी स्ट्रीम चेक किया ब्लैंक।
तो ऐसा क्यों हो रहा है? क्योंकि
हम डील कर रहे हैं इंक्रिप्टेड ट्रैफिक के
साथ। जो सेशन है आपका इंक्रिप्टेड है। हम
किसके साथ डील कर रहे हैं? हम डील कर रहे
हैं इंक्रिप्टेड ट्रैफिक के साथ। तो भाई
बात ऐसी है तो जब हम आरटीपी सर्च कर रहे
हो हमारे पास कोई भी पैकेट नहीं दिखाई दे
रहा अगर वहीं पर अगर हम टीएलएस सॉरी शिप
सर्च कर रहे हैं तब भी हमें कोई पैकेट
नहीं दिखाई दे रहा ओके तो
अब मुझे किस टाइप के पैकेट्स को देखना
पड़ेगा
अब इसके लिए हमें किस टाइप के पैकेट को
एनालाइज करना पड़ेगा इसके अंदर कोई गेस कर
सकता है और काफी जो आपका जो बेसिक
नेटवर्किंग है उसी से रिलेटेड एक प्रकार
से जो बेसिक नेटवर्किंग का सवाल है सवाल
यह है कि जब आप ऑडियो और वीडियो के साथ
डील करते हो खासकर की ऑडियो डाटा और
वीडियो डाटा उस टाइम पर किस प्रकार का
प्रोटोकॉल यूज़ किया जाता है या ऑडियो और
वीडियो के केस में कौन से टाइप का
प्रोटोकॉल यूज़ किया जाता है?
बेसिक नेटवर्किंग का सवाल है कि जब हम कोई
भी ऑडियो पैकेट या वीडियो पैकेट के साथ
डील करते हैं, जब हम वीडियो कॉल करते हैं,
ऑडियो कॉल करते हैं, तो तब हम कौन से
प्रोटोकॉल के साथ डील करते हैं? बताओ।
हैं? बताइए कौन से प्रोटोकॉल के साथ डील
करते हैं?
ओके। विजय ने बोला यूडीपी, काव्या ने बोला
एफटीपी और बताइए
किसी का कोई अलग आंसर।
किसके साथ डील करते हैं?
ओके।
कुंडू ने बोला यूडीपी और कोई
क्या तीन ही स्टूडेंट्स को पता है? बाकी
किसी को कोई भी नॉलेज नहीं है। स्टन ओके
यूडीपी
लाइव वीडियो यूडीपी
काफी अच्छा Google किया।
ओके। तो बिल्कुल सही बात है। जब हम वीडियो
और ऑडियो पैकेट की बात करें तो हम किसके
साथ डील करते हैं? यूडीपी के साथ। तो चलिए
भैया हम एक काम करते हैं। अब यूडीपी और
सर्च कर लेते हैं इसके अंदर। क्या इसके
अंदर यूडीपी है? भाई। भाई यूडीपी पैकेट्स
की तो भरमार लिस्ट लगी हुई है। देखो
यूडीपी यूडीपी है। यूडीपी ही यूडीपी
पैकेट्स हैं। इतने सारे यूडीपी पैकेट्स
हैं। बट क्या मुझे यह बताइए कि ओनली
आरटीपी प्रोटोकॉल ही ऐसा है जो यूडीपी के
साथ काम करता है या यूडीपी के साथ और भी
प्रोटोकॉल्स काम करते हैं। बताओ क्या
अकेला आरटीपी प्रोटोकॉल ही ऐसा है जो
यूडीपी के साथ काम करता है या दूसरे
प्रोटोकॉल्स भी हैं जो यूडीपी के साथ काम
करते हैं बताओ
जल्दी से बताओ
क्योंकि देखो थोड़ा सा सेशन को इंटरेक्टिव
बनाते हैं क्योंकि थोड़ी सी नॉलेज आप शेयर
कीजिए बाकी बची हुई नॉलेज मैं आपसे शेयर
करूंगा आप थोड़ी सी कष्ट कीजिए अपने आपको
थोड़ी सी पेन लीजिए नॉलेज शेयर करने के
लिए बाकी मैं हूं आप लोगों के लिए तो बताओ
क्या आरटीपी पैकेट ही यूडीपी के साथ काम
करता है या और भी पैकेट्स हैं जो यूडीपी
के बेस पर काम करते हैं?
थोड़ा बहुत आईडिया दीजिए थोड़ा सा बताइए।
नो
और कौन-कौन से प्रोटोकॉल्स हैं जो यूडीपी
के साथ काम करते हैं? फिर
कोई भी एक प्रोटोकॉल का नाम बताइए।
बताओ यूडीपी के साथ और कौन-कौन से
प्रोटोकॉल्स है जो काम करते हैं? आप बोल
रखिए अकेले जो आरटीपी है वह काम नहीं
करता। बाकी और भी प्रोटोकॉल्स हैं जो इसके
साथ में काम करते हैं। तो बताइए फिर
कौन-कौन से?
थोड़ी सी रोशनी डालिए। थोड़ा सा बताइए।
ओ हो और
ओके।
हां। डीएनएस भी यूडीपी के बेस पर काम करता
है। डीएसीपी भी यूडीपी के बेस पर काम करता
है। टीएफटीपी भी यूडीपी के बेस पर काम
करता है। और ऐसे बहुत सारे प्रोटोकॉल्स है
जो यूडीपी के बेस पर काम करते हैं। अब इस
सिनेरियो में हम कैसे पता करेंगे कि इसमें
इस यूडीपी पैकेट्स में कौन सा
डीएनएस है, कौन सा डीएपी है या फिर हमारा
आरटीपी है। अब यह हम कैसे पता करेंगे? तो,
यह चीज़ पता करने के लिए YX आर्क में एक
सेक्शन होता है। वह सेक्शन क्या है? अब
स्टैटिस्टिक्स सेक्शन होता है। ये रहा।
यहां पर जाओगे स्टैटिस्टिक्स सेक्शन के
अंदर आपको जाना है। और आपको किसके अंदर
जाना है? प्रोटोकॉल हरार्की। आपको कहां
किसके अंदर जाना है? प्रोटोकॉल हरारकी। अब
जब आप प्रोटोकॉल हरार्की देखोगे, मैं इसको
ज़ूम कर देता हूं। होगी तो तो मुझे लगता
नहीं है ज़ूम हो पाएगी।
मैक्सिमाइज नहीं करेंगे। मिनिमाइज भी नहीं
करेंगे। तो हम आपको दिखा देता हूं। यह रहा
तो सबको दिखाई दे रहा नहीं दिखाई दे रहा।
दिखाई दे रहा है।
इसको जरा एडिट नहीं करेंगे। मैं आपको दिखा
देता हूं। ये दिखाई दे रहा होगा शायद। आई
होप यस तो यहां पर देखोगे कि जो आपकी
हायरार्की है हरार्की में बहुत सारी चीजें
आप नोटिस करोगे यहां पर देखो फ्रेम है
प्रोटोकॉल फ्रेम
कितने टोटल पैकेट है 4862 पैकेट 48 4862
पैकेट है इथर आईपी वर्जन सिक्स यूडीपी अब
यूडीपी पैकेट्स देखोगे आप ठीक है IPV6 में
यह है अब IPV4 में देखो
99.9
पैकेट्स किसके ऊपर ट्रैवल कर रहे हैं?
यूडीपी पैकेट्स। किसके अंदर? आईपीवी4 के
अंदर। यूडीपी के पैकेट के अंदर कितने यूज़
कर रहे हैं? 99.64843
जो पैकेट्स है वो यूडीपी प्रोटोकॉल के
अंदर ट्रेवल कर रहे हैं। जिनमें से आप
देखोगे कि 98.3
पैकेट्स कौन यूज़ कर रहा है? डाटा। फिर
उसके बाद रियल टाइम ट्रांसपोर्ट कंट्रोल
प्रोटोकॉल 276%
नेट बॉयस नेम सर्विस2%
लिंक लोकल मल्टीकास्ट नेम रेोल्यूशन 2% और
डीएनएस4%
तो सोचो देखिए कहां यहां चीजें काम कर रही
होंगी यह देखो ध्यान से इस हरारकी को
ध्यान से इससे एक चीज क्लियर होती है कि
99.9%
यूडीपी ट्रैफिक है जिन इनमें से टीसीपी
ट्रैफिक कितना है? देखो आप टीसीपी ट्रैफिक
दिखाई दे रहा है कहीं पर आईसीएमपी ये
इसमें टीसीपी ट्रैफिक दिख नहीं रहा वैसे
और ओके ये जो डाटा नहीं है खोलते हैं ये
रहा
इसमें टीसीपी आपको एसएसएल देखने को नहीं
मिल रहा बट
देखने को मिलना चाहिए था क्योंकि अभी-अभी
अपडेट हुआ है मेरा वायरस तो मे बी इट इज़
नॉट एबल टू सी बट वह भी हम देख लेंगे तो
एक चीज़ क्लियर है यूडीपी पैकेट्स है लेकिन
लेकिन यहां पे एक टर्म देखने को मिली होगी
आपको रियल टाइम ट्रांसपोर्ट कंट्रोल
प्रोटोकॉल आरटीसीपी
आरटीसीपी
यहां देखने को मिली होगी आपको आरटीसीपी यह
क्या होता है जो आपका रियल टाइम
ट्रांसपोर्ट कंट्रोल प्रोटोकॉल्स होता है
वो एक स्पेशल प्रोटोकॉल्स होता है
जो क्या करता है आपके आरटीपी प्रोटोकॉल के
साथ काम करता है जो आपके आरटीपी प्रोटोकॉल
के साथ काम करता है और जो आपका आरटीपी है
वह
यूडीपी के ऊपर काम करता है। जैसे मैंने
आपको बताया ना कि जो आपका रियल टाइम
ट्रांसपोर्ट कंट्रोल प्रोटोकॉल्स है वह
आरटीपी के साथ कर काम करता है और आरटीपी
यूडीपी के बेस पे काम करता है। लेकिन
क्यों काम करता है? क्योंकि आप अकेले
यूडीपी पे ट्रस्ट नहीं कर सकते। क्योंकि
यूडीपी क्या है? कनेक्शन लेस प्रोटोकॉल
है। सबको पता है यह चीज जो यूडीपी है आपका
कनेक्शन लेस प्रोटोकॉल है। इसलिए आप
यूडीपी पे विश्वास नहीं कर यूडीपी पे
विश्वास नहीं करते। आप उस पर ट्रस्ट नहीं
करते। इसीलिए क्या है कि आरटीसीपी
प्रोटोकॉल का यूज़ किया जाता है आरटीपी
प्रोटोकॉल के साथ। क्योंकि एक बात सोचने
की बात है जितनी भी ज़ूम मीटिंग है, जितनी
भी Microsoft की टीम मीटिंग है, Google
मीट्स की बात करें डिस्कॉर्ड की बात करें
या WhatsApp वीडियो कॉल की बात करें या
ऑडियो कॉल की बात करें आप सभी
एप्लीकेशनेशंस पे भरोसा क्यों करते हो?
क्योंकि
उनके साथ जो आरटीसीपी प्रोटोकॉल्स है वो
आरटीपी के साथ काम करता है। आप अकेले
यूडीपी के बेस पे उनके ऊपर ट्रस्ट नहीं
करते। अकेले यूडीपी के बेस पर अगर आपको
बोला जाए कि ये एप्लीकेशनेशंस ओनली यूडीपी
को यूज करेंगी आपके डाटा को ट्रांसफर करने
के लिए तो उस केस में कभी भी आप अकेले
इन एप्लीकेशनेशंस पे ट्रस्ट नहीं करोगे।
आप ट्रस्ट इसलिए करते हो क्योंकि जो
आरटीसीपी प्रोटोकॉल्स है वह आरटीपी के साथ
मिलकर काम करता है और वह यूडीपी प्रोटोकॉल
का यूज करते हैं आपकी ऑडियो ट्रैवल के लिए
क्योंकि अभी सिनेरियो बदल चुका है अभी तक
हम क्या देख रहे थे हम शिप और आरडीपी को
देख रहे थे तो चलिए भैया क्या आरटीसीपी
प्रोटोकॉल अवेलेबल्स है तो ध्यान से
देखोगे ये देखो यूडीपी प्रोटोकॉल्स यूडीपी
प्रोटोकॉल्स और ये देखो यहां बीच में
आरटीसीपी प्रोटोकॉल्स देखोगे और ये क्या
है कि आरटीसीपी प्रोटोकॉल्स कंटिन्यू नहीं
होगा। लेकिन एक इंडिकेशन होता है कि जहां
पर आरटीसीपी प्रोटोकॉल्स है तो उसके ऊपर
नीचे जहां पर भी आप क्या करोगे एक बार
क्लिक करके देखोगे तो वो 100% क्या होगा
आपका लगभग क्या है आपका आरटीपी प्रोटो जो
आप किसका ट्रैफिक होगा आपका आरटीपी
ट्रैफिक होगा तो अगर आपको यकीन नहीं होता
तो यकीन करना पड़ेगा कैसे करेंगे चलो इसको
देखते हैं हम यकीन के लिए चलो ये देखो
सोर्स पोर्ट क्या है 4000 डेस्टिनेशन
पोर्ट क्या है 12668 से डाटा यह रहा देखो
डाटा में है 172 की लेंथ यह कुछ डाटा है
बिल्कुल सही है अब यह रहा यूडीपी यह भी
सेम है यहां देखो आरटीसीपी प्रोटोकॉल देखो
रियल टाइम ट्रांसफर कंट्रोल प्रोटोकॉल्स
ये क्या है बीच में आपके क्योंकि देखो
यूडीपी कनेक्शन लेस है तो लेकिन आपके डेटा
को एरर लॉस बनाने के लिए उसको ट्रैक करने
के लिए किसका यूज़ किया जाता है आपके
आरटीसीपी प्रोटोकॉल का यूज़ किया जाता है
तो इसलिए यहां पर बीच-बीच में इसका यूज़
रहता है ताकि डाटा की गारंटी बनी रहे।
ओके? कभी भी आप वो नहीं है कि यूडीपी के
तरह आपका कनेक्शन लेस काम करता है। यह तो
यह कारण है। तो आपको पता चल गया यूडीपी।
और एक और चीज है कि जब यहां पर आप फिल्टर
भी लगाओगे आपने फिल्टर लगाया आरटीसीपी
प्रोटोकॉल। देख लो आरटीसीपी प्रोटोकॉल्स
में बहुत सारे हैं। वैसे तो देखो सेंडर
पोर्ट रिसीवर रिपोर्ट पोर्ट है ये सोर्स
डेस्टिनेशन ये है। बट एक और चीज आपको बता
देता हूं कि वायरस आर्क में जब हमने
टेलीफोनिक किया सिर्फ फ्लो किया और यहां
पर कुछ भी नहीं दिखाई दिया उसका कारण क्या
है?
उसका कारण क्या है? उसका कारण है कि
जब इससे पहले आप डील कर रहे थे किसके साथ?
जो आपका सेशन प्रोटोकॉल था शिप प्रोटोकॉल
था वह इंक्रिप्टेड नहीं था वह टीएलएस के
ऊपर नहीं था और आरटीपी भी आपका
अनइंकिप्टेड
था लेकिन जो आपने नोटिस की होगी जो शिप
प्रोटोकॉल है जब वो हैंडक करता है जब सेशन
इनिशिएट होता है तो वो एसडीपी पैकेट्स को
सेंड करता है सेशन डिस्क्रिप्शन पैकेज
जिसके अंदर आपके पोर्ट्स होते हैं आपका
मीडिया डिस्क्रिप्शन होता है और जो वायरस
आर क्या करता है कि वायर आर इसी एसडीपी
पैकेट को रीड करता है और रीड करने के बाद
आपको वह सारी चीजें रिप्रेजेंट कर पाता
था। लेकिन अब हुआ क्या है? जो शिप है शिप
को कर दिया इंक्रिप्टेड मतलब टीएलएस के
साथ ऐड कर दिया। टीएलएस के साथ ऐड कर दिया
तो क्या होगा? आज आपका शिप क्या हो गया?
इंक्रिप्टेड हो गया। जब शिप इंक्रिप्टेड
हो गया तो एसडीपी की इंफॉर्मेशन को वसआर
रीड आउट नहीं कर पा रहा। और जब वसार उस
इंफॉर्मेशन को रीड आउट नहीं कर पा रहा। तो
इसी वजह से क्या हुआ आपको यहां पर सब कुछ
ब्लैंक देखने को मिलता है। यहां पर सब कुछ
आपको ब्लैंक देखने को मिलता है। अगर मैं
यहां पर एसएसएल सर्च करूं तो आप देख लोगे
एसएसएल पूरा हैंडशक टाइप से देखो यहां पर
प्ले बिल्कुल कोई भी देखो क्लाइंट हेलो
सर्वर हेलो सर्टिफिकेट एक्सचेंज हुआ
एप्लीकेशन डाटा कुछ भी अब यहां पे देखो
अभी तक तो यह देखो यहां पर सेशन इनिशिएशन
प्रोटोकॉल शिप प्रोटोकॉल
ठीक है यहां पे देखोगे यहां क्लाइंट हेलो
है यहां पर कोई शिप प्रोटोकॉल नहीं है
सर्वर हेलो है सबको पता है कि हैंडशक होता
है टीएलएस में उसके बाद देखो सर्टिफिकेट
एक्सचेंज हो गए न्यू सेशन टिकट क्रिएट हो
गई। देन उसके बाद जब एप्लीकेशन डाटा की
बात आए तो सेशन इनिशिएशन प्रोटोकॉल
स्टार्ट हो गया। सेशन इनिशिएशन प्रोटोकॉल
स्टार्ट हो गया। इसी कारण से क्या वो
चीजें आपकी उसमें काम नहीं कर रही। तो
भैया बात ऐसी है यह एक चीज तो आपको पता चल
गई कि आपका शिप क्या है? इंक्रिप्टेड है।
उसको आप डिक्रिप्ट नहीं कर सकते। क्योंकि
उसको डिक्रिप्ट करने के लिए हमारे पास की
होनी चाहिए। हमें उन नॉलेज उन एल्गोरिदम्स
की नॉलेज होनी चाहिए जो इसकी की को जनरेट
करती है। ओके या इसकी की को इस एल्गोरिदम
को जो रोटेट करती है वो इंफॉर्मेशन होनी
चाहिए और हमारे पास वो कोई भी इंफॉर्मेशन
नहीं है। ना हमारे पास कोई की है ना हमें
पता कि किस टाइप की एल्गोरिदम यूज़ की जा
रही है या हमें यह नहीं पता कि वो
एल्गोरिदम कैसे की को जनरेट कर रही है। और
जब तक हमारे पास यह इनेशन नहीं है वी कैन
नॉट डिक्रिप्ट द ट्रैफिक। इसलिए हम क्या
कर सकते हैं? शिप के ट्रैफिक को अभी
डिक्रिप्ट नहीं कर सकते। तो बात रही क्या
कि आरटीपी पैकेट पैकेट की क्योंकि शिप
आपका इंक्रिप्टेड है ना कि आरटीपी। आरटीपी
आपका डिक्रिप्टेड है। उसके लिए आपको क्या
करना है? यहां पर सर्च करना है। फिल्टर
लगाना है यूडीपी। आप यूडीपी पे जाओगे।
पहला तरीका मैं आपको बता रहा हूं। जब आप
यूडीपी पे जाओगे दे लॉट ऑफ़ प्रोटोकॉल्स आर
अवेलेबल्स इन यूडीपी। और ये आरटी आरटीसीपी
प्रोटोकॉल्स है। इसके आगे पीछे हम क्या
करना है? यहां पर क्या है? कहीं पर भी
क्लिक किया और क्लिक करने के बाद राइट
क्लिक। राइट क्लिक करने के बाद आपको जाना
है डिकोड एज। डिकोड एज पे क्लिक करना है।
समझ में आ गया? मैं फिर से आपको बता देता
हूं। यूडीपी पैकेट सेलेक्ट करना है। राइट
क्लिक करना है और डिकोड एज। यहां पर डिकोड
एज पर जाना है। यहां तक सबको स्टेप क्लियर
है? यहां तक सबको स्टेप क्लियर है या नहीं
है? जल्दी से बताइए चैट में।
क्योंकि यह सेशंस हैं। सच में मैं आपको
बताऊं कि आपको नेटवर्क की नॉलेज नहीं है
या आपको बेसिक नॉलेज नहीं है नेटवर्क की
या और भी फंडामेंटल्स आपके क्लियर नहीं है
या आपको वाईएसआर यूज़ नहीं करना आता। आपको
यूडीपी की नॉलेज नहीं है, टीसीपी की नॉलेज
नहीं है या आईपी जो टी आप बोल सकते ओएसआई
मॉडल की नॉलेज नहीं है तो उस तब तक आप
क्या है कि यह चीज समझ ही नहीं पाओगे।
इसीलिए हर कोई आपको बोलता है कि बेसिक
फंडामेंटल्स ऑफ नेटवर्किंग आपके लिए बहुत
ज्यादा जरूरी है। जिसमें आपको पता होना
चाहिए कि चीजें कैसे काम करती है। ओएसआई
मॉड्यूल आपका क्लियर होना चाहिए। टीसीपी,
यूडीपी, डीएनएस, डीएचईपी, आईपीवी फोर
आईपीवी सिक्स सबनेटिंग ये सारी चीजें आपकी
एटलीस्ट क्लियर होनी चाहिए क्योंकि
यू आर ए साइबर सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट या
साइबर सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर की जब आप बात
करोगे तो उसके लिए आपके बहुत सारे
मैंडेटरी स्कोप होते हैं जो आपको टिक
मार्क करने होते हैं जो फुलफिल करने होते
हैं ओके
यू कैन नॉट सर्च थ्रू इनवाइट सिंक क्योंकि
इसमें इनवाइट है ही नहीं ब्रो वो है ही
नहीं वह आपको मिलेगा ही नहीं मैं आपको
दिखाऊंगा कि इनवाइट स्ट्रिंग हम फाइंड आउट
कर पाएंगे नहीं कर पाएंगे। डोंट वरी। मैं
वाईसआर का सीएलआई के थ्रू दिखाऊंगा। अभी
देखना अभी आपको बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग मैं
चीजें आपको स्टेप बाय स्टेप बता रहा हूं।
तो यह पता चल गई। तो आपको डिकोड एज पे
जाना है। यहां पर क्लिक करना है और
सेलेक्ट कर यहां पर सेलेक्ट करना है
आरटीपी।
यहां पर सेलेक्ट करना है आरटीपी। क्योंकि
हम यूडीपी पैकेट को आरटीपी में कन्वर्ट कर
रहे हैं। क्योंकि हमें आईडिया मिल गया। यह
रहा आरटीपी। जैसे सेलेक्ट करेंगे, सेव
करेंगे, यहां पर सारे के सारे पैकेट कौन
से आ गए आपके? आरटीपी पैकेट्स आ गए। आ गए
सारे के सारे पैकेट आरटीपी जैसे आपको
स्टार्टिंग में दिखाई दे रहे थे। सबको समझ
में आ गया? सबको दिखाई दे रहा है? अभी
आरटीपी पैकेट सबको दिखाई दे गया? अभी दिख
रहे हैं ना?
एवरीवन जल्दी से चैट में बताइए। तो अभी हम
क्या कर सकते हैं? अभी हम जाएंगे टेलीफोनी
गो टू आरटीपी और आरटीपी स्ट्रीम एनालिसिस
पे जाते हैं अब की बार हम और जैसे हम
आरटीपी स्ट्रीम एनालिसिस पे जाएंगे तो अभी
हमारे आरटीपी पैकेट्स आ गए उससे पहले नहीं
थे यह देखो यह सारे हमारे आरटीपी पैकेट्स
है और जैसे आप क्या करो प्ले स्ट्रीम पे
जाओगे यह है आपका आरटीपी पैकेट और मैं अभी
क्या करता हूं उसको रन करके दिखाता हूं और
आप ध्यान से सुनना
दिस इज कॉलर टू वेलकम टू अडमी
सबको सुनाई दिया
सबको सुनाई दिया एवरीवन
सुनाई दिया होगा ना सबको बिल्कुल परफेक्ट
तो चलिए ये था आपका वाईएसआर के थ्रू अभी
हम चलते हैं एक्चुअल चीज के ऊपर क्योंकि
ये तो वएसआर के थ्रू होती रहती है चीजें
अभी हम सीएलआई के थ्रू भी देखते हैं
क्योंकि आपने जिंदगी में कभी किस-किस ने
यहां पर टीसारक यूज़ किया है कितने
स्टूडेंट्स ऐसे हैं जिसको जिसने टी शार्क
को यूज़ किया मतलब आपका जो वायरस शार्क है
उसका सीएलआई वर्जन को यूज़ किया है। कितने
लोगों ने यूज़ किया है? बताओ कितने लोगों
ने यहां पर यूज़ किया है?
पता है यूज़ नहीं किया तो अच्छी बात है।
चलो आज हम पता भी करवाते हैं और आपको यूज़
करना भी सिखा देते हैं। चलो एक और अच्छे
बेहतरीन टूल है जिसके साथ में आपको
इंट्रोडक्शन उसका यूसेज दिखाता हूं कि
कैसे यूज़ होता है। मैं वह सिखा देता हूं
आपको। बाकी धीरे-धीरे क्लासेस चलती रहेंग।
धीरे-धीरे आप लोगों को नॉलेज होती रहेगी।
वह एक अलग सिनेरियो हो जाएगा। ओके?
मुझे पता है किसी ने यूज़ लेकिन वो भी काफी
पावरफुल है।
मुझे पता है किसी ने।
ओके। तो चलिए फिर हम एक काम करते हैं। अभी
वार के ऊपर चलते हैं।
इस आर के ऊपर आई एम
आई एम टेकिंग माय वर्ड बैक।
जस्ट मुझे मुझे मुझे थोड़ा सा टाइम दीजिए।
बस आई एम ओपनिंग माय सम कमांड्स ताकि आप
लोगों को
चीजें और भी क्लेरिटी मिल जाए। आपको एक
अप्रोच में समझाता हूं।
तो हम चलते हैं। हां एक और चीज मैं आपको
बताया था। लास्ट क्लास में हमारा क्या चीज
थी कि ये था पिककैप टू वेव कि जो
स्क्रिप्ट नहीं मिल रही थी। ये रही आपकी
पिककैप टू वेव की स्क्रिप्ट। मैं आपको
कंट्रोल सी और आपको पेस्ट कर देता हूं।
इधर यह रहा इंटेंट। यहां पर चलिए आप इसको
यूज कर लेना। आपको क्या करना है? जस्ट
यहां पर क्लिक करना है रो पर और यहां पर
इसको क्लिक करना है। जैसे कि मैं आपको
बताया था कंट्रोल सी फिर डब्ल्यू गेट
कमांड का यूज़ करना है और आप इसको डाउनलोड
करना है। सबको सब लोग शायद इसको कर पाओगे।
सब लोग कर पाओगे। मुझे पता है आप लोगों पर
विश्वास है कि आप लोग कर पाओगे। तो अभी हम
चलते हैं यहां पर। तो मैं एलएस करता हूं।
यहां पर तीन कॉल है। कॉल टू वॉइस मेल
कॉन्फ्रेंस कॉल थ्री पार्टीज नॉर्मल कॉल
टू पार्टीज पी कैप और यह क्या है? आपकी
नॉर्मल कॉल्स नहीं है। जैसे कि आपको दिख
रहा है यह वो है शिप ओवर टीएलएस प्लस में
आरटीपी मतलब सेशन आपका इंक्रिप्टेड है और
आरटीपी आपका अनइंकिप्टेड है। तो चलिए फिर
सबसे पहले हम क्या करते हैं? कमांड होती
है वह क्योंकि जब आप वायसर इंस्टॉल करते
हो वs का जो सूट है उसके साथ यह कमांड आती
है वह कमांड होती है आपकी कैप इनफो कैप
इनफोस उसके बाद हम यूज़ करेंगे आपकी पिकैप
फाइल तो सबसे पहले हम कौन सी पिकैप फाइल
हम यूज़ करने वाले हैं नॉर्मल पिकैप फाइल
फाइल को यूज़ करने वाले हैं हिट एंटर ये
क्या करता है ये आपके जो पिकैप फाइल है
उसके मेटे जो मेटा डाटा है उसको
रिप्रेजेंट करता है शो करता है मेटा डाटा
में बहुत कुछ है। जैसे कि आप अभी देख
पाओगे। हम इसको देख पाते हैं कि इसमें
क्या-क्या है मेटा डाटा में। तो आप सबसे
पहले आपको पहले लाइन में क्या दिखाई दे
रहा है? फाइल नेम। फाइल नेम क्या है?
नॉर्मल कॉल टू पार्टीज पिक फाइल। नॉर्मल
कॉल टू पार्टीज पिकैप फाइल। फाइल टाइप का
है। क्या है? वायसआर की टीसीपी मतलब पिकैप
फाइल है। उसके बाद थर्ड वन क्या है आपका?
फाइल इनकैप्सुलेशन। मतलब इसका मतलब क्या
है? कि इसको जो कैप्चर किया गया किससे?
आपके इथर से। मतलब कि इथरनेट केबल आपका
लोकल नेटवर्क है। उसी से इसको क्या किया
गया है? कैप्चर किया है। मतलब चाहे वह
स्विच से कनेक्ट हो, चाहे आपके किसी लोकल
नेटवर्क से कनेक्टेड है। तब इसको कनेक्ट
किया था। मतलब यहां पर इथर आ गया। ओके?
उसके बाद यहां पर क्या आया आपका? टाइम
स्टेप टाइम स्पेंड यह टाइम एक्यूरेसी को
दे रहा है। उसके बाद पैकेट साइज लिमिट।
यहां पर
पैकेट साइज लिमिट। इस पैकेट का साइज क्या
है? कितने बाइट का पैकेट है?
262144 बाइट का नंबर ऑफ पैकेट्स कितने हैं
इसके अंदर? 4965
फाइल का साइज कितना है? 1.153
1.153 KB मतलब 1.1 MB डाटा का साइज क्या
है? 1MB
कैप्चर ड्यूरेशन
कितने सेकंड? 51 सेकंड की कॉल ड्यूरेशन
है।
अर्लियस्ट पैकेट टाइम मतलब टाइम बता रहा
है कब से मतलब उसकी कैप्चरिंग के टाइम है।
देखो यह रहा 250
इससे लेकर लेटेस्ट पैकेट टाइम। ठीक है? यह
आपकी टाइम लिमिट बता रहा है। आप टाइम
लिमिट मतलब हम बोल सकते हैं कि
क्या समझे इसको कि
क्या समझ सकते हैं इसको और
मैं आपको बताऊं तो इसको समझ सकते हैं हम
कि कला ये जो ये कॉल है कब स्टार्ट हुई
अर्लिस्ट कब कॉल को स्टार्ट हुई और कब कॉल
एंड हुई उसकी ड्यूरेशन आप बोल सकते हो
डेटा बाइट रेट क्या है 21 KB पर सेकंड
बाइट रेट थी बिट रेट क्या है डेटा की 168
KBP है तो इतनी सारी इंफॉर्मेशन है। यह
इसके फिंगरप्रिंट है। इसके यह इसके
फिंगरप्रिंट है। उसके बाद इतनी सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन आपको देखने को मिल रही है।
बिना किसी पिकैप को देखे हुए बिना पिकैप
को छुए हुए वे जस्ट हम क्या करें? उसका
मेटा डाटा देख के आईडिया लगा रहे हैं।
नेक्स्ट कमांड हम यूज़ करेंगे। नेक्स्ट
कमांड होती है। अब TS शार्क का हम यूज़ कर
रहे हैं। अब टी शार्क की अगर हेल्प फाइल
देखें हम टी शार्क
आपके में इंस्टॉल नहीं होगा तो आपको करना
पड़ेगा। TSR हफन हफन हेल्प फाइल हिट एंटर
देखो बहुत बड़ी टू बहुत बड़ा टूल्स है और
काफी प्रोफेशनल टूल्स है। आप अपने ऑटोमेशन
पर्पस के लिए इसको आसानी से यूज़ कर सकते
हैं। अगर आपको स्क्रिप्टिंग आती है आपको
Python स्क्रिप्टिंग बेच स्क्रिप्टिंग
Python स्क्रिप्टिंग तो आप क्या कर सकते
हो? इसको बहुत अच्छे से यूज़ कर सकते हो।
बट इसके ऑप्शंस को समझना बहुत जरूरी है।
यहां पे देखोगे TSRK है क्या करता है? डंप
एंड एनालाइज नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक। ये आपका
सीएलआई वर्जन है किसका?
वसार का बेसिकली तो हर एक ऑप्शन को हम कवर
नहीं कर सकते लेकिन जो जो हम ऑप्शन कवर
करने वाले हैं उनको समझ लेते हैं तो उनको
समझने के लिए हम क्या करने वाले हैं अभी
हम क्या करते हैं क्लियर ट्रैफिक कर देते
हैं नेक्स्ट तो अभी हम यूज़ कर रहे हैं टी
शार्क
टी शार्क आपको कमांड दिखाई दे रही होगी
बिल्कुल अभी हम यूज़ करने वाले हैं हफन आर
हफन आर का मतलब क्या हो सकता है कि पिकअप
फाइल हमें पिकअप फाइल प्रोवाइड करो तो
पिकअप फाइल कौन सी है मेरी नॉर्मल कॉल टू
पिक कैप उसके बाद हफन q क्वाइट साइलेंटली
हफन जेड हम क्या करने वाले हैं हफन जेड से
हफन z से हम देखने वाले हैं
कि
कौन-कौन से प्रोटोकॉल्स मतलब जो आपने क्या
किया था अभी आपने अभी एक चीज देखी थी
स्टैटस्टिक्स के अंदर जाकर प्रोटोकॉल
हरार्की तो प्रोटोकॉल हरार्की देखने के
लिए आप यूज़ कर सकते हो क्या यूज कर सकते
हो ये रही हफन जेड इसमें कुछ ऑप्शंस होते
हैं। आईओ कॉमा पीएचएस
यह ऑप्शंस होते हैं। यह क्या करता है?
साइलेंट हफन जेड यह प्रोटोकॉल हरार्की को
रिप्रेजेंट करेगा। एग्जैक्टली देखो हीट
एंटर सेम दिखाई दे रहा है। फ्रेम इथर आईपी
यूडीपी डीएनएस एलएलएमआर एनडीबीएस आरटीसीपी
आरटीसीपी डाटा टीसीपी टीएलएस अभी डिटेल्स
में आया। पिछली बार टीएलएस की इंफॉर्मेशन
नहीं थी। वही सेम है। बिल्कुल सेम एरर की
है। देखो यहां पर फ्रेम में 4965 पैकेट्स
हैं। इथनेट में 4965 है। यूडीपी पैकेट
कितने यूज़ किए जा रहे हैं? यहां से देखोगे
डीएनएस के लिए कितने पैकेट? 18
एलएमएआर ये क्या है? लोकल उसके लिए है।
नेम रेजोलशंस के लिए 10 पैकेट। नेट बायर्स
के लिए नौ पैकेट। आरटीसीपी के लिए 27
पैकेट। यह देखो ध्यान से डाटा के लिए
टीसीपी के लिए 93 जिसमें टीएलएस है 51
पिछली बार टीसीपी टीएलएस आपको देखने को
नहीं मिल रहा था लेकिन यहां पर आपको देखने
को मिल रहा है पिछली बार नहीं देखने को
मिल रहा था बिल्कुल क्लियर है सारी चीजें
आपको क्लियर हो गई यहां पर कि क्या-क्या
चीजें हमें देखने को मिल रही है क्या-क्या
चीजें नहीं देखने को मिल रही तो एक चीज तो
हमें इसकी हरारकी पता चल गई है प्रोटोकॉल
हरार्की तो नेक्स्ट कमांड हम क्या यूज़ कर
सकते हैं चलिए फिर हम नेक्स्ट कमांड में
क्या-क्या यूज़ कर सकते हैं मैं आपको कमांड
बताता हूं। सबको समझ में आ रहा है ना
गाइज?
सबको समझ में आ रहा है ना या बहुत हार्ड
लग रहा है? बताओ। हार्ड तो लगेगा क्योंकि
टॉपिक ही आप लोगों के लिए एडवांस है भैया।
एडवांस में तो चीजें हार्ड होती हैं। होती
है ना? अब जैसे कि हम इसमें सर्च कैसे कर
सकते हैं? जैसे हमने उसमें सर्च किया था।
शिप आरटीपी वो भी सर्च कर सकते हैं। तो
सर्च करने के लिए कैसे यूज़ करेंगे हम? टी
शार्क
उसके बाद
इसको इंस्टॉल कैसे करना है? आपको इंस्टॉल
करने का तरीका बता देता हूं। ए मैं सूडो
एपीटी इंस्टॉल
उसके बाद टीs
टीs बस पासवर्ड एंटर करो और आप इसको
इंस्टॉल कर पाओगे।
सिंपल इतना ही है। इतना ही है।
जगत गुरुजी समझ में आ गया। इतना ही है।
कैसे इंस्टॉल करना है? तो क्लियर हो गया
सबको? मैं आपको दिखा रहा था टीs को यूज़
करना। तो Tarार्क है। यहां तक हमने कर
लिया था। अभी साइलेंट को हम हटा देते हैं।
हफन वाई का यूज़ करके दिखाता हूं। पहले मैं
हफन वाई। यहां पर हम सर्च कर रहे हैं।
सर्च करने के लिए मैं सबसे यूज़ करने वाला
हूं क्या? शिप पैकेट। इसमें है या नहीं
है? हिट एंटर सिर्फ पैकेट नहीं है। चलो
आरटीपी पैकेट को सर्च करके दिखाता हूं।
आरटीपी पैकेट है नहीं है। वहीं पर अगर आप
बोलोगे यूडीपी पैकेट
है। यूडीपी पैकेट्स है। आगे बिल्कुल जैसे
आप वहां पर देख पाते थे। यह आपकी यूडीपी
पैकेट्स। सेम उसी तरीके से आप देख पा रहे
हो। यूडीपी पैकेट। तो, यह चीज़ आपको क्लियर
हो गई। तो अभी मैं आपको एक और चीज दिखाता
हूं कि इसमें हम क्या चेक करने की कोशिश
करते हैं? हम चेक करने की कोशिश करते हैं
कि
स्ट्रीम है या नहीं है। स्ट्रीम स्ट्रीम
चेक करने की कोशिश करते हैं। तो एक कमांड
होती है इसमें हम क्या चेक करने मैं
क्लियर करता हूं। इसके अंदर ये रहा अभी
अभी हम यूज़ कर रहे हैं। कौन सी ये हफन वाई
की जगह हफन q क्वाइट ये सारी कमांड आप लिख
लेना। हफन जेड उसके बाद हम देख रहे हैं
आरटीपी स्ट्रीम
आरटीपी स्ट्रीम्स और हिट एंटर
हिट एंटर आरटीपी स्ट्रीम्स
यह वाला सिनेरियो है जब आपने क्या किया आप
गए किसके अंदर टेलीफोनी टेलीफोनिक के अंदर
आप गए आरटीपी आरटीपी में स्ट्रीम गए और
वहां पर आपको कुछ भी नहीं देखने को मिला
था यहां पर भी आपको कुछ भी नहीं देखने को
मिल रहा क्यों नहीं देखने को मिल
क्यों नहीं देखने को मिल रहा?
क्योंकि आरटीपी स्ट्रीम शो नहीं हो रही।
क्योंकि आपकी जो आरटीपी स्ट्रीम है वह शो
नहीं हो रही। इसीलिए आपको यहां पर कुछ भी
देखने को नहीं मिल रहा। इसलिए आपको यहां
पर कुछ भी देखने को नहीं मिल रहा। क्योंकि
हमें पहले यूडीपी को आरटीपी में कन्वर्ट
करना होगा। यूडीपी को आरटीपी में कन्वर्ट
करना होगा। सेम वही तरीका हो गया क्योंकि
यह भी एसडीपी को रीड करता है लेकिन एसडीपी
प्रोटोकॉल क्या है आपका शिप के साथ है और
शिप आपका इंक्रिप्टेड है तो उसके लिए एक
कमांड है हमारे लिए कौन सी कमांड आप यूज़
कर सकते हो वो कमांड आपकी
हमारी कमांड है
वह कमांड हमारी यह रही। मैं आपको दिखा
देता हूं।
बहुत सारी कमांड है। मैं आपको इसमें से एक
कमांड दिखा दूं आपको।
यह रही वो कमांड आपकी टी शार्क हफन आर
नॉर्मल कॉल टू पार्टीज हफन वाई यूडीपी हफन
टी मैं फील्ड सेलेक्ट कर रहा हूं। उसके
बाद हफन यूडीp डॉट सोर्स पोर्ट यूडीp डॉट
डेस्टिनेशन पोर्ट शॉर्ट और यूनिक शॉर्ट और
यूनिक और हिट एंटर कर देता हूं मैं। यह
देखो अभी यहां पर आपको क्या करना है? यहां
पर आपको क्या करना है? यहां पर आपको
एनालाइज करना है पोर्ट को कि कौन से पोर्ट
पर सबसे ज्यादा
कौन से पोर्ट पर सबसे ज्यादा ट्रैफिक है।
देखो 4000 यह 40001
बिल्कुल इससे कोई मतलब नहीं है। सबसे
ज्यादा ट्रैफिक देखो यह रहा 4000 और यह
वाला फिर यह रहा 4000 4000 40001 40001
यह डीएनएस ट्रैफिक है। तो कोई लॉजिक नहीं
है। तो सबसे ज्यादा ट्रैफिक कहां पर है?
इन पर है। सबसे ज्यादा ट्रैफिक और
इंटरेस्टिंग ट्रैफिक हमारे लिए इन्हीं का
ही है। क्योंकि 53 डीएनए स्पोर्ट हमारे
किसी काम का नहीं है। 5355 आपके एलएलएमआर
जो आपका प्रोटोकॉल्स है। एलएलएमआर
प्रोटोकॉल्स आपका लोकल नेट लोकल नेटवर्क
नेम रेजोलेशंस के काम आता है। एलएलएमएआर
होता है। ठीक है? लोकल नेम रेजोलेशंस के
काम आता है। 137 नेट बायोस है। तो यह किसी
काम के नहीं है। हमारे लिए इंटरेस्टिंग
पोर्ट तो यही है। 4000 आपको पता है आरटीपी
4000 आप 40001 समझ सकते हो आप। आरटीसीपी
क्या बाय डिफॉल्ट पोर्ट है। तो चलिए भैया
नेक्स्ट कमांड हमारी क्या रहेगी? हमें
इतनी चीजें श्योर तो हो गई। तो अब हम क्या
कर सकते हैं? फ़्टर लगा सकते हैं। अब फ़्टर
कैसे लगाएंगे? चलो भैया। कैसे लगाएंगे?
फ़्टर देख लो। फ़्टर लगाने का तरीका। अब मैं
इसको क्लियर कर देता हूं। थोड़ा सा हार्ड
है। मैं बता रहा हूं। समझ रहा हूं बट समझ
जाओगे आप लोग। अभी यह रहा
यहां तक कमांड आपकी सेम रहने वाली है। टी
शार्क हफन आर नॉर्मल कॉल टू पार्ट इज हम
यूज़ करने वाले हैं हफन डी। हफन डी और आपको
अगर हेल्प फाइल देखनी है। चलो मैं आपको एक
और चीज दिखा देता हूं। अभी एक काम टी
शार्क हफन डी आप यूज़ करने वाले हो। हफन डी
और हेल्प फाइल देख लो भाई। हफन डी में
क्या-क्या ऑप्शन है? देखो ये रहा। हफन डी
के साथ इतने सारे ऑप्शंस को आप यूज़ कर
सकते हो। हफन डी के साथ आप इतने सारे
ऑप्शंस को यूज़ कर सकते हो। ऐसे नहीं है।
बहुत बड़ा टूल है ये। देखो हफन डी के साथ
इतने सारे ऑप्शंस को यूज़ कर सकते हो।
टीसार ये लेयर आप यूज़ कर सकते हो। ओके? तो
हम क्यों क्या यूज़ करने वाले हैं अभी?
यूडीपी पोर्ट। हम पोर्ट को कंपेयर कर रहे
हैं। ठीक है? इसको यूज़ करेंगे हम। किसको?
अह वेद यू यू यू डीपी पी क्यू आर यू यू यू
जी यह रहा हम यूज़ करेंगे यूडीp डॉट पोर्ट
यह रहा हम ये यूज़ करने वाले हैं इसके साथ
हम ये यूज़ करने वाले हैं यूडीp डॉट पोर्ट
तो चलिए फिर हम स्क्रीन को क्लियर कर देते
हैं ये चीज़ सबको इंटरेस्ट आ रहा है या
बहुत ज्यादा हार्ड पड़ रही है चीजें बताओ
आप लोग
पिकअप फाइल हफन डी हम यूज़ करने वाले हैं
अभी यूडीपी यूडीपी डॉट पोर्ट इक्वल इक्वल
4000 हमने रखा डॉट आरटीपी प्रोटोकॉल्स
आरटीपी प्रोटोकॉल्स
अब जैसे एंटर करेंगे हम आरटीपी
प्रोटोकॉल्स जैसे ही एंटर करेंगे तो ध्यान
से देखना
है यहां पर ट्रैफिक तो है 4000 पर इतना
सारा ट्रैफिक है 4000 का और 40001 का इससे
ज्यादा ट्रैफिक होगा 4000 1 का इसका
ज्यादा ट्रैफिक होगा। अब हम एक बढ़िया सी
कमांड लगाते हैं। यहां पर क्वाइट हार्ड तो
है भैया। सच में हार्ड है यह। ऐसे नहीं
है। एक बढ़िया सी कमांड लगाएंगे। वो कमांड
कौन सी है? मैं आपको ऐड याद करवा देता
हूं। वो आपकी कमांड होगी
आरटीपी यू डीपी नॉर्मल टू कवरटी। ये रहा।
आपकी हम कमांड यूज़ करने वाले हैं। मैं
आपको कॉपी कर लेता हूं अभी के लिए
और अभी के लिए मैं क्लियर कर देता हूं
स्क्रीन को और
पेस्ट कमांड को देखो
टीशार्क हफन डी पोर्ट 4000
आरटीपी हफन डी 40001 आरtp
hन आर नॉर्मल कॉल टू पार्टीज हफन क्विक
साइलेंटली hन z आरटीपी स्ट्रीम्स को देखना
चाहता हूं। उससे पहले ये खाली आया था
लास्ट टाइम अगर आपने देखा होगा। ठीक है?
बिल्कुल टीसार आप लोगों को आईडिया नहीं है
ना कभी आपने टीs को यूज़ किया नहीं है। आज
आप टीसार की पावर देख लो। ओके? और
धीरे-धीरे आप इसको भी यूज़ करना सीख जाओगे
इन फ्यूचर में। तो इसलिए बता रहा हूं कि
आप मुझसे पढ़ रहे हो और मुझसे जब आप चीजें
पढ़ोगे ना तो भाई आप सोच लो कि आप
क्या-क्या चीज सीखने वाले हो मुझसे। पता
चल गया। कि मैं आपको कुछ भी चीज ऐसे ही
नहीं सिखाता। एवरीथिंग इज वेरी प्रिशियस
टू एवरीवन। तो जैसे एंटर किया यह देखो
स्ट्रीम तो बनी है।
अब स्ट्रीम तो बन गई। अब स्ट्रीम तो बन
गई। ठीक है? अब स्ट्रीम तो बन गई। यहां पर
टोटल चार स्ट्रीम आपको देखने को मिल रही
हैं। पहली स्ट्रीम देखोगे। यह रही
पहले इनका ऑप्शन देखो। स्टार्ट टाइम एंड
टाइम सोर्स पोर्ट
डेस्टिनेशन आईपी एंड पोर्ट एसएसआरसी कोड
है पेलोड किस टाइप का है पैकेज लॉस्ट एक
भी नहीं हुआ है टाइम तो यहां पर देखो कि
पहला क्या है यह रही पहली स्ट्रीम यह है
दूसरी स्ट्रीम यह है
तीसरी स्ट्रीम यह है फोर्थ स्ट्रीम यह है
ठीक है? फोर स्ट्रीम यह है। चार स्ट्रिम
आपको देखना। अगर इनको मैं थोड़ा सा और
अच्छे से अरेंज करवाऊं, तो हम यूज़ क्या कर
सकते हैं? कॉलन टी यूज़ कर सकते हैं ना
शायद। एक ऑप्शन होता है ना हमारे पास कॉलन
टी। कौन सा ऑप्शन यूज़ कर सकते हैं हम?
कॉलन टी।
हम हम शायद शायद शायद
स्पेलिंग मुझे अभी याद नहीं आ रही। वि
ऑप्शन इज बेटर वन
कॉलन टी कोलन टी लिखते हैं ना क्या लिखते
हैं
इसको देख ही लेता हूं
पहले भी मैं यूज़ कर चुका हूं इसको
यह रहा सेम कमांड है हिट एंटर। तो अभी
थोड़ा सा अरेंज वे में आपको देखने को मिल
रही है। अभी थोड़ी सी अरेंज वे में आपको
देखने को मिल रही है। तो कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है। तो एक चीज तो क्लियर होगी कि
इसके अंदर चार स्ट्रीम्स है। मतलब दो
लोगों की बातचीत है। दो लोगों की बातचीत
है। ओके। तो चलो फिर देरी किस चीज की यह
तो आपको पता चल गई। अभी आप लोगों को एक
चीज और दिखाता हूं इंटरेस्टिंग। अब थोड़ी
बहुत बेस्ट स्क्रिप्टिंग करें। यहां पर
थोड़ी बहुत बेस्ट स्क्रिप्टिंग करें।
यहां से हमें एक चीज तो पता चल गई। हम
स्ट्रीम लेकर आ गए। आरटीपी स्ट्रीम देख
देख पा रहे हैं। चार स्ट्रीम है। बेस्ट
स्क्रिप्टिंग देखनी है सबको थोड़ी सी। तो
चलिए फिर एक काम करते हैं। इसको क्लियर
करते हैं अभी और एक बार मैं आपको क्या
दिखाता हूं? एक टूल था ना हमारे पास
पी कैप टू वेव ये रहा ये टूल था ना पिककैप
टू वेव उसके बाद अगर मैं इसको नॉर्म इसको
वो करने की कोशिश करता हूं। देखो ये रहा
अनेबल टू डिटरमाइन कोडक फ्रॉम पेलोड टाइप।
मैं नहीं कर पा रहा। भाई क्या करूं?
चलिए फिर हम इसको एनालाइज करते हैं। क्यों
नहीं कर पा रहे आप? तो हम चलते हैं इसके
अंदर ओपन फोल्डर और यहां पर टूल कहां पर
है? वIP के अंदर। यह आपका टूल है। इसको हम
ओपन कर लेते हैं एक बार। इसको माउस वड ओपन
विद माउस पैड के साथ ओपन कर लेते हैं। यह
आपकी स्क्रिप्ट है। यह आपकी बेस्ट
स्क्रिप्ट है। यह आपकी बेस्ट स्क्रिप्ट
है। अब इसमें देखोगे तो देखो कंडीशंस हैं
बहुत सारी। इफ इफ एल्स कंडीशन ये देखो आप
कभी आपने बेस्ट स्क्रिप्टिंग की होगी
क्योंकि मैंने तो सिखाई भी है ये इफ
कंडीशन देन एल्स और ये देखो यहां पर इसमें
टी सार का यूज़ किया जा रहा है ये रहा टी
सारक हफन एन हफन आर हफन वाई हफन टी फील्ड
हफन ई फील्ड हफन यूडीपी डेस्टिनेशन पोर्ट
यह रहा कुछ अलग नहीं है देखो एक यह रहा
देन उसी के नीचे होगा एक और यह
एंड यह रहा पिलोइड के अंदर भी क्या है? टी
शार्क है और एक एंड में होगी। मतलब टी
शार्क के रिजल्ट के बेसिस पर ही यह आपको
क्या करता है? कन्वर्ट करके दे रहा है। तो
चलिए थोड़ी बहुत हम भी बेस्ट स्क्रिप्टिंग
करते हैं। बेस्ट स्क्रिप्टिंग में क्या
करते हैं? यह इफ एल्स कंडीशन है। यहां यह
आपको अगर याद होगा डॉलर 2 डॉलर 3 आपका
क्या होता है? जब हम ऑप्शंस प्रोवाइड करते
हैं ना टूल्स के अंदर जैसे आपने क्या
किया? यह अभी हमने टूल यूज़ किया था। यह
रहा
यह डॉलर 2 डॉलर 34
डॉलर 56 ये होते हैं आपके डॉलर 1 2 3 4 ये
उसी की बात हो रही है तो चलो हम एक काम
करते हैं इसको मॉडिफाई करते हैं और एक हम
खुद का वेरिएबल डिफाइन करते हैं इसमें खुद
का वेरिएबल क्या डिफाइन करेंगे खुद का
वेरिएबल डिफाइन करने के लिए हम यूज़ करते
हैं हम यूज़ करेंगे अभी हम क्या ऐड करेंगे
इसके अंदर इसके अंदर ऐड करते हैं वेरिएबल
नेम हम रखते हैं
हम हम डिकोड
डिकोडर
डिकोडर इक्वल साइन
डॉलर फोर और ये सेम चीज यहां पर ऐड करेंगे
हम डिकोडर
हम इसी को मॉडिफाई कर रहे हैं। चलो आज
आपको मैं स्क्रिप्ट को भी मॉडिफाई करना
दिखा देता हूं। ठीक है? डिकोडर इक्वल साइन
डॉलर थ्री क्यों किया? क्योंकि अभी मैं
क्या कर रहा हूं कि ऑप्शंस में थर्ड ऑप्शन
दूंगा क्योंकि हम हमारे टूल की कमी क्या
थी कि यह डिकोड नहीं कर रहा था। जैसे हमने
किया था ना वार्क में डिकोड एज तो हम वही
कर रहे हैं। डिकोड एज हम किससे कर रहे थे?
अगर आपने नोटिस किया होगा कि अगर हम इसके
अंदर जाएंगे ये रहा
यहां पे ए ये रहा।
यहां पर कर रहे हैं ना हम ये वही चीज
करें। डिकोड एज आरटीपी
डिकोड एज आरटीपी वही चीज हम यहां पर यूज़
करेंगे अभी तो हम कैसे करेंगे स्क्रिप्ट
के अंदर चलो चलते हैं डिकोड अभी इसको बाद
इसके बाद हम इसको क्या करते हैं कॉपी कर
लेते हैं
कॉपी एंड उसके बाद चलते हैं नीचे उसको तो
हमने बना लिया पहली पहली कमांड कहां पर है
पहली कमांड होगी ये रही पहली
वेयर इज माय
फर्स्ट फर्स्ट टीशार कमांड इज देयर ये
रही। और इसको हम कहां पर याद करेंगे? यहां
पर ऐड करेंगे। यहां पर ऐड करेंगे डॉलर के
साथ। क्योंकि डॉलर और वेरिएबल नेम देंगे
तो उससे क्या होगा? आपका
वेरिएबल की वैल्यू यहां पर फैच हो जाएगी।
चलो इसको अभी हम पूरा कॉपी करते हैं
क्योंकि हमें कई जगह देना पड़ेगा। कंट्रोल
सी और फिर नेक्स्ट हमारा कहां है? पेलोड
टाइप के अंदर भी इसके आगे दे देंगे।
कंट्रोल वी डिकोडर उसके बाद एक और है एक
और एक और एक और कहां पर है टी शार्क
इज माय टी शार्क वेयर इज माय टी शार्क
माय अनदर टी शार्क यह रही चलिए कंट्रोल वी
हो गया और कंट्रोल एस करते हैं और मैं
कंट्रोल एफ कर लेता हूं टी शार्क
देखो एक
नो यह चेंज हो गया। इसकी जरूरत नहीं चेंज
करने की। इसकी जरूरत नहीं है चेंज करने
की। इसकी भी नहीं है। हां, पहली कमांड
चेंज हो गई। दूसरी कमांड चेंज हो गई।
तीसरी कमांड चेंज हो गई। बस हो गया। सारी
कमांड हमारी चेंज हो चुकी है। और कंट्रोल
s हम कर चुके हैं इसको। और इसको क्लोज कर
देते हैं हम स्क्रिप्ट को। स्क्रिप्ट को
हमने क्लोज कर दिया। यहां तक सबको समझ में
आ गया? यहां तक सबको समझ में आ गया चीजें।
क्लियर
क्लियर अगर आपको देखना है कैट पिक
पिकैप टू वेव और उसके बाद गैब करना है
आपको वो भी देख लोगे चेंज गैब और हम दे
रहे हैं टी
टी शार्क हिट एंटर यह रहे ऑप्शंस जो हमने
चेंज किए हुए हैं डिकोडर अब इसको यूज़ कैसे
करेंगे तो चलो फिर डॉलर पिकैप टू वेव उसके
बाद नॉर्मल टू कॉल पार्टीज उसके बाद हम
क्या करते थे? उसके बाद एक वेरिएबल का नाम
देते थे। तो हम रखते हैं अभी हम
एक फाइल का नाम देते थे नॉर्मल कॉल नॉर्मल
अंडरस्कोर कॉल। उसके बाद हमने रखा अब
देंगे हम डबल कोट के अंदर हफन डी। और क्या
रखने वाले हैं हम हफन डी के अंदर? अगर आप
लोगों को याद नहीं है तो हफन डी के अंदर
रखने वाले हैं हम यूडीपी पोर्ट
यूडीपी
डॉट यही था आईप डॉट पोर्ट उसके बाद इक्वल
इक्वल 4000 कॉमा आरटीपी देखो टूल का
मॉडिफिकेशंस हम कर रहे हैं यहां पर हिट और
यह रहा डबल कोट के अंदर बंद यूज करके
दिखाएं हिट एंटर टूल इज वर्किंग और नॉट
टूल ने काम किया अपना।